allora se non c'è martin garics omar
tigris o hardware o skrillex a fare il
dj
io non entro ok sono sicuro ma non credo
che questo non sia scrive chi come voi
mi guarda con l'occhio lino ascolta zio
e devo entrare cescrin l'ex per cortesia
che dov'è il dj eccolo lì ciao
sì sì tu martin garris che cazzo fai
così che la musica fucka garzanti 04 non
sempre mendo niente va da solo cioè la
console che va da sola se non stai
facendo niente non è per essere razzisti
e per carità di dio però non mi
ricordavo che martin harris fosse nero o
skrillex deve fare così va bene sulle
mani ragazzo le mani su eva ha compreso
bene bravo mori che stanca che domani
mori questo e john travolta incolte
questo nascondere un coltello qua sotto
spiegami perchè giorno e non militare in
faccia grazie
questo è tipico boss mafioso che fi e
che fu che film non fumati ma che fi ma
nel a ceteroni sopra attenzione sto
analizzando locale prima di partire con
gli schiaffi perché sono resta a 6 lo
chef tony che vende i coltelli no scusa
non volevo farti cazzare merda merda
merda sopra le teste questi si picchiano
la rissa ragazzi scoppiata rehab berman
dammi un jack daniels danni oggettivi e
va bene anche questo che vuoto ok ora mi
sono pagato in mano pronuncia più la
guancia
senti zio e non mi difendere sé un
barista del cazzo questa è la grappa di
mio nonno
red ila ecco vedi che fa male d'alcol
sempre detto io senti robin hood per
farmi capire c'è dal tipo che ci aveva
il coltello che è sparito ed è sparito
giustamente anche il coltello però io ho
un posacenere bastardo ecco infatti le
di posacenere cosa in grado di fare
spada o il cazzo sei noi ascia sto
cercando se tieni della droga c'è anche
il sesso non avevo visto che c'è
l'accesso
vabbè lo zio no è mai basso soffitto non
era basso il soffitto non riusciva a
saltarli in testa pazienza ma buono
ragazzi abbiano capito come il locale
ora so cosa fare queste aree al cesso
per vedere cosa succede
il bello ragazzi che la gente si
nasconde mentre fuma non devono farsi
vedere che fumano posso prendere questa
cosa ti incazzi qualcosa mi dice che un
locale per fumatori ragazzi vedi che il
fumo fa male ti fa sparire gli arti te
lo dice lo zio favi non si fuma perché
il fumo fa male quindi ti do una
badilata in testa per farti capire
ecco di sicuro stai meglio come ho fatto
ha staccato un braccio con una mazza da
baseball non lo so e vabbè vabbè seo
sono svenuti via veloce che non capisco
un cazzo che non ho ancora capito perché
io devo lanciare piatti ma il dj
continua farm drago zio continua a far
bene ride
vai con remix che tanto la gente si
picchia io ti fotto le luci e non
possono vecchi foto la console chi foto
la mamma cosa ti fatto tra tutti quelli
che si velano ragazzi c'è uno che lui
che si fa beatamente i cazzi suoi ma se
lo picchio si muove posso usare questa
cosa si incazzato zio non te lo chiedo
si incazza sì sì ho trovato il coltello
dentro l'occhio e invece no è morto è
morto
quindi adesso posso prendere lo scettro
questo è la madonna è un simbolo dei
dollari sono questo non c'è braccio devi
morire
porca eva alla madonna small ecolo la
gente che cazzo è così forte da small e
colare le persone mischia al pettine
cioè il pettine incastrato in testa l'ho
preso perchè devo usare lo shockwave
faccio un disastro negozi usa la poi ve
lo dico eh vabbè proviamoci
shockwave mica fatto un devasto questo è
un pezzo decente bravo zio forse non ti
ucciderò non ti caga nessuno basta fare
così a parte sto tizio che ha [ __ ] la
cassa ricarica non c'era sto casino
neanche in casa mia quando portava un 4
me senti zio mi fai un favore metti
quella musica seria maledizione non
resta rally vita è normale ovvio è
volato era numero mai è normale che il
cazzo di ricorda metti una roba un po
più seria bravo sarà trasmesso questa
sera questo sì che serie poi questo c'è
ancora la bottiglia nell'occhio ciò che
ho mica anni beh siete morti no perché
se non ce l'ha soddisfatta che sciocco i
ragazzi non serve una mazza parte
buttarli a terra
ho trovato una mazza parlando di marzo
ho trovato una mazza entrate forza 12 è
questo è morto già 18 34 dio 458 mariga
impossibile
sono vivo come ho fatto a salvarmi non
lo so raga mi manca pochissimo e sono
morte ve lo dico eh vabbè da dove
spuntano
cazzo e jovanotti
[Musica]
da medico del mondo ma devo fare una
provata regate vuole saltare sopra tutti
e vabbè interesse armato questi ho vinto
il problema è che sono troppo forti
perché c'è un tipo con la spada o
remaining 9 la massa dove da dove
spuntata ma è grande e vabbè devi creare
zio beh se no va bene che devo provarci
berserk no cos'era adesso adesso bravo
ancora uno bravissimo ci siamo stronzo
di merda medico vieni qua se addio
michael ha tirato il pugno l'altro e non
crepa o è morto non ci credo ho fatto
ragazzi sono fatta lo prende la squadra
se li prendo la spada o vinto perché con
la squadra ce la faccio rega devo solo
prenderlo spa dal tizio c'è la tensione
a mille la mira la mira della madonna
e vabbè stavo scherzando celo celo celo
oh oh oh oh oh dio nel morto ma con tre
manca 2 dove cazzo sono gli altri due e
dice l'ho ucciso
e chi pensa che mette jovanotti non ho
ucciso io dj cosa volete
1 se ho vinto non ci credo mezz'ora
perché mica faccio io faccio io ragazzi
sulle mani tutti i giubilei
piatto incastrato c'era che ha fatto un
casino a un certo punto credevo di
perdere assolutamente perché si sta roba
eh va beh
spiegami che come come faceva a sapere
che c'è non stai armi rosso si esce e
stato bello ragazzi è stato bello
discoteca del cazzo perché è perché gli
alcolici costano troppo quindi ho fatto
un po di casino scusate è stato bello
bellissimo ragazzuoli è stato strano
però va bene quale c'è la prigione che
ho già fatto li ho fatti tutti ragazzi
tranne sandbox dei level
e ancora questo in teoria sì però non
credo sia un livello ma mor coming soon
va beh sembra minecraft vabbè le armi
seriamente perché ancora non li avete
messer spiegatemelo alti studi prima
vediamo quanto in quanto in quanti colpi
moriva mickey è fortissimo sarebbe morto
subito con il fucile mica è fortissimo
tom corsa nuovo è possibile
no vabbè un non morto tra se avesse
continuato a camminare anche così mi
sarei sorpreso e credimi zio vieni ti
organizzi all inizio passa zio passa zio
è la madonna o mio dio voglio fare una
cosa fermi fermi ho deciso
ho deciso deciso decisone di oh oh mio
dio che trick che l'ha ucciso sul serio
360 non scopo e vabbè ma come lo zio non
volevo in gas e tis castro io perfetto
sei morto dignitosamente seriamente ma
da ma che figo qual è il bordello
oddio la strage la strage dei fermi
attimo
madonna è vero è che cosa siete voi hulk
ancora infierite pure bastardi papa
ragazzi era solo per vedere però è una
figata voglio vedere se riescono a
mettere armi e robe decenti nei prossimi
livelli no perché sarà una figata buona
ragazzuoli spara che vi sia piaciuto
cosa sento se vi è piaciuto l'argomento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come nei video tratte nella
descrizione city se poi ci vediamo al
vostro vino le ragazze